[Music]
I'm interrupting this cinematic slow-mo
montage because this is so beautiful it
is the most perfect coral color when I
saw this at the Apple event I actually
freaked out and now I'm having another
freak out because it's here in my hands
and it matches my hibiscus Apple watch
band slow-mo montage continued
[Music]
[Applause]
here it is the iPhone 10 are in coral
this is probably one of my favorite
colors and I was so excited when I was
at the actual event and saw these for
the first time in real life this was the
color that I gravitated to it comes in
six colors total this is the coral it
also comes in black blue white red and
yellow this is my favorite I also really
like the color of the yellow it was so
vibrant but the good news is for myself
but not my credit card I bought all six
colors so stay tuned for the unboxing of
all six of those but today we're just
gonna talk about some of the features
I'm gonna be doing an extensive camera
test a lot of my reviews do focus a lot
on the camera and video because for me
personally that is what I do most of
that is like my entire life revolves
around creating content for you guys and
even when I'm not creating stuff for you
I like capturing these memories for
myself so being able to have a great
phone that takes incredible photos and
videos with me at all times is such a
great thing and the best part about this
the 10r is it has so many features that
it shares with the 10s and the 10s max
it even after using this for the past
couple of days as my main phone it's
almost difficult to tell the difference
between the two my main phone since it
came out has been the iPhone 10's max
and in comparison to the 10r you can see
that the size is it really that much
smaller than the Tenace max also
slightly bigger than a 10s just by a
little bit the biggest physical
difference is the display of course
aside from the colors this is a 6.1 inch
liquid retina HD display Apple says that
this is the largest LCD they've ever had
on an iPhone now you might be saying
Justine but the 10s max is bigger than
the 10r yes that is because that screen
is not an LCD the iPhone 10's max is a
6.5 inch super retina OLED whereas the
10 s is a 5.8 inch super retina OLED
what that means is the displays on the
tennis and the tennis max are a little
bit higher resolution than the 10r so
that's one of the ways they're able to
make this phone way more cost efficient
another physical difference is the band
around this phone is made of aluminum
instead of stainless steel so not only
are you cutting some costs there but
you're also making this phone so much
lighter than the other two this chairs
so many similarities with the 10 s and
the 10
smacks that I feel like most people
aren't even going to notice a difference
like I don't even think that you can
tell if you're holding it up next to
each other attend are also features face
ID it has the all glass back it has the
durable glass front in 12 Bionic chip
it's water resistant up to one meter it
has stereo sound it also will do
wireless charging has the dual SIM all
of this just like the 10s but one of the
other big differences is it only has one
camera so much like its little friend
here the 10s the 10 are features the
same wide-angle lens and larger sensor
about the 10 F has 70 just imported no
done both of these phones are really
excited because the portrait mode on the
10r is surprisingly incredible and
what's different is there's only one
lens as opposed to the two of it is on
the 10s 10 in the 10s max so you can see
over here on the 10s max it's way more
zoomed in because it's using the
telephoto for portrait mode and the 10 R
is not it's using to do one lens that it
has and as the wide-angle was
I'm actually super impressed with only
one lens it no longer does the zoom
portrait like the 10s or the 10s max or
the 10 so this took a few shots to get
used to let's carry on take some a
picture but overall I was super
impressed with how well this worked on
these shots
[Music]
the corner road on the ice antenna are
is only supposed to detect people much
like the previous phone where it kind of
consents different depths you can get
some pretty decent portrait mode shots
of your animals and pets and whatever
else is in frame but because this only
has one lens it uses various algorithms
to detect people no person detected
supporter mode so now to see if it'll
detect me oh it's already detected you
are you the adjustable aperture has been
one of my favorite things in these new
phones
it doesn't just blur the background it
accurately tries to replicate the bokeh
that a DSR lens would create when
switching up the aperture I always tend
to focus so much on the portrait mode
photos because it is what kind of makes
these phones unique now is being able to
take these shots on a phone it
essentially will replicate a shot that
you would be getting with a high-end
expensive camera with an incredible lens
it's everyone's favorite thing to
criticize portrait mode shots zoom it
and see where there's artifacts or
details are left out or where something
should have been blurred and it should
have been blurred whatever it is no
matter what phone it is I feel like a
lot of people do that and I think it's
pretty fair because it is something that
is new in the past couple of years it is
great to see that it has been getting so
much better I'm not just on the iPhone
but on other phones as well even just
regular photos on the 10s and the 10s
Macs and the 10th are are amazing
obviously because they do share pretty
much the same front and back camera it's
like I said you've only got one God the
spoon looks so good I just every time I
look at it I'm just it takes my breath
away
so the Smarties yard is a really great
job of kind of leveling out photos
whether it's too bright or too dark it
pulls out shadows where they need to be
pulled out the highlights that can bring
them down so it's taking a bunch of
photos at the same time and then
magically stitching them all together to
give you one perfect photo so there was
a huge Beauty gate controversy where
people were saying that the iPhone was
blurring their skin trying to make you
have a flawless complexion which a lot
of times it may seem that that's what
it's doing but because this smart HDR
pulls out a lot of the shadows you can
tell in this photo specifically this is
shot on a 10 and it's a shot on the new
10 our is pulling out all of the shadows
around my face so yeah it may actually
be giving sort of a skin smoothing
effect but this photo that was shot on
the 10r I think looks way better than
shot on the 10th
maybe the 10 was over pixel izing our
photos and the 10 are is just
normalizing them and making us look
fantastic
we've been talking a lot about photos
let's not forget the video 10 are also
shoots 60 frames a second at 4k also 4k
30 and we'll shoot slow-mo in 240 at
1080p I shot an entire mini vlog using
the 10r and it was crazy because I
really felt like I was just using the
10s but I was editing the footage like
it looked exactly the same
[Music]
hey guys today we're at Kualoa ranch and
i am testing out the brand new iphone
pen our why don't you share with the
rest of the class I think we can
[Music]
to the 10r is the battery life has been
increased by an hour and a half so if
you're comparing the 10r to the iPhone 8
this will get you an extra hour and a
half battery and I have definitely
noticed the battery life on this has
been amazing so I felt that this has
been on par with what my tennis max has
been getting with the release of Erica
to developers have been working on so
many more things for the iPhone and with
the a12 Bionic chip you're getting so
much more power and everything is so
much faster the ability for AR apps to
just be seamlessly integrated into your
daily life like shopping have you guys
experienced augmented reality shopping
yet it might be my new favorite thing I
saw it for the first time at a WDC demo
I was like this is the future well the
future is now here so the first one
we're gonna do is this Magnolia bag so
anytime you see this little icon you can
click that obviously this isn't going to
be on every website but if it is
something that developers have on a site
you can see what this will look like in
real life okay so here it is you can
scan around you can zoom in but I want
to see what its gonna look like on this
beautiful couch right here yeah I know
right it's freaking cool and I can move
it around but that's not even the
coolest part about it I'm getting so
close to this bag I can freakin see the
buckle oh my gosh
the only time that I tried this out was
a demo and this is the first time that
I'm doing this myself no no okay I'm
you're gonna think I'm overreacting but
this is so cool so I can also put it
somewhere else if I say whoo what would
it look like over here by breeze room
this is something that I know you'll be
into Jenna if they bicycle
what I got it back all the way up so I
can see this bike in full view hey Bri
come here and see this bike don't run
into the bike what you actually stand by
it so how big it is okay that's nice
you're kind on it okay but let me know
what you guys think of arrow shopping is
this a future do you love it you think
it's crazy you do have an iphone with
this enabled definitely go try it out
and let me know what you guys think
another app that I'm really excited to
try that I'll be doing a video on later
on it's called home court so it helps
you track your shots and it will help
you train to become a better basketball
player and I'm not very good at
basketball but I do plan on testing this
out so maybe I can find somebody who is
actually good at basketball to help me
with this but just this whole concept of
using your phone and augmented reality
to help you train better for whatever is
that you're training for I absolutely
love yoga and I've been doing that very
consistently this year and I think it
would be so cool to have an augmented
reality yoga app maybe there is one if
there isn't somebody please work on this
there are so many other iterations of AR
that I think it would be so much fun
there's a Sims game where you can take
your sin and put it in the real world I
had never played Sims on the iPhone and
I feel like it is the most perfect game
for the iPhone because you could just
zoom in why am i zooming in on my
virtual hand I can bring the game up I
have mail oh yeah I'll play my rewards
you can zoom you can move around
everything is touch so when you're
building you just kind of drop things in
move around I think I found a new fun
iPhone game that I'm gonna play and I am
upset with myself because I feel like
it's going to suck a lot of my time in
just like previous Sims games so
all-in-all my takeaway from using the
10r is I think it is the most affordable
and most powerful phone that Apple has
ever created for people and it is
beautiful it is fast this thing has been
really awesome and going from the 10s
max to this for the past couple of days
it's been crazy because I thought that I
would be able to tell a difference but I
really haven't at all even when taking
photos the portrait mode is really cool
I've been really enjoying the single
lens portrait mode it's kind of
impressed with all of the photos that I
was able to achieve with that so if you
are in the market for a new iPhone
you're probably saying Justine which
phone do I get I don't know
I can't answer that for you that is a
very personal thing you now have three
models to choose from you have two sides
in the 10s and three colors in each and
you have six different color options in
the 10r so this is kind of overwhelming
I'm overwhelmed just thinking about it
and making this video so honestly if I
were to suggest a phone for you to get
if I had to this pen are for the price
and for what you're getting I mean this
is it's it really is perfect thanks for
watching I will see you guys in my next
video I have a bunch of fun ones coming
up so if you aren't already subscribed
to my channel be sure to do so and make
sure you hit the bell so you'll be
alerted when I post new videos I wanna
know from you guys which ten hour color
is your favorites also which phone do
you currently have and lastly please be
kind in the comments I will see you guys
soon bye
[Music]